george clooney knew exactly what he was
doing for him and his father it was the
cost of getting this message across
we're here really to ask two very simple
questions
the first question is something
immediate and immediately we need
humanitarian aid to be allowed into the
sudan before it becomes the worst
humanitarian crisis in the world
immediately
ladies and gentlemen they've crossed the
police line this is your third and final
warning you will be arrested step this
way
minutes later when they refused police
requests to move on they were arrested
hands tied and led into the back of a
police van
what led him there was this
15 bombs hit this
tiny village where everyone is hiding in
the rocks
you're a very brave boy
there is no mistaking clooney's passion
for raising awareness of what he says is
a looming humanitarian crisis in sudan
he's just returned from a visit with
this video
there's your bullets
there
he's branded sudan's president bashir a
war criminal who merits international
attention
four hours in custody guarantees a star
like clooney a global audience
you never know if you're accomplishing
anything all we're trying to do is bring
attention to a moment
in time that is actually important
it was the culmination of a week that
seen him plead his case on capitol hill
and in a meeting at the white house
he also had some powerful dining
companions at a state dinner with the
prime minister to make his argument
it is my first arrest thanks for asking
and let's hope it's my life
a 100 fine a small price to pay for a
stunt that achieved exactly what was
intended
greg milam sky news washington